greetings and welcome to call of cthulhu
the official adaptation of Kaos eum's
tabletop RPG from focus Home Interactive
and cyanide studio this is you Edward
Pierce War veteran private investigator
struggling alcoholic you come to the
near forgotten dark water island to look
into the deaths of the Hawkins family
after an inferno engulfed their stately
home well here we are
our kids match
1693 this house is much older than it
seems
whoa you are trying to force the door
you nosy prick easy sir all right put
down the X you know what we do a trouble
like you
we gut them dump them into the ocean
whoa aah
you're mr. Winchester lower that ax
let's talk
don't show me how we have it out on dark
water to the encounter with
groundskeeper Winchester can be resolved
in a number of ways
intimidation subterfuge good
old-fashioned sneaking
it's your choice your skills will
determine your fate and are improved
throughout your journey rest in peace
follow me I know the place
incidental details will tie into your
understanding of what happened to the
Hawkins family and the story of the
island as a whole your skills will
determine how much knowledge you can
glean from a painting a book or original
circle the Last Supper for Hawkins what
does this tell me
they seem happy but Charles is already
looking off into the future he's managed
just to stop along the way let's see if
I can find something that cops missed
they had a fight
Pierce is not a magical being but he is
extremely perceptive and a great
investigator then Sara Hawkins Lewis one
of her shoes how the child's corpse left
a trace during these reconstruction
scenes you find clues to quite literally
build a picture of what happened
did someone escape the fire the more
clues you find the more you will know
heading into conversations and other
situations in the future if the painting
I found on the docks
really came from here how come it didn't
burn of course in Call of Cthulhu
knowledge has a price and blissful
ignorance is sometimes preferred the
more you discover the closer you come to
truth the further you push your sanity
to the brink and risk the abyss of map
[Music]
your journey is just beginning
[Music]
you